[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Gadi Ezra hold an
unparalleled perspective
on war, as both a human
rights attorney on one hand
and a soldier in Israeli
Special Forces on the other.
He is currently advising
the Defense Establishment
on International Aspects
while pursuing his PhD in law.
Gadi is a Forbes 30
under 30 honoree,
and holds already
three law degrees
from both Tel Aviv
University and NYU
School of Law specializing in
public law and human rights.
At NYU, Gadi was
the first Israeli
chosen to deliver the
convocation speech
on behalf of his classmates.
Previously he served
as a legal advisor
in the Israeli Ministry
of Foreign Affairs,
and was selected to clerk
directly for the State Attorney
of Israel, Mr.
Moshe Lador, where
he participated in cardinal
decision-making processes.
Drawing from his personal
experience as well as
his strong academic and
practical background
as a human rights lawyer,
Gadi examines the complexities
of applying the laws of
warfare in actual combat.
So with that,
please welcome Gadi.
[APPLAUSE]
GADI EZRA: All right.
Can everybody hear me?
All right.
So good afternoon and
thank you for coming.
We were walking in
the building, and it's
a beautiful, beautiful building
environment and a lovely winter
day in the city.
However, I'm here to talk to
you about a less pleasant issue.
I'm here to talk
to you about war.
War in one word, really, if
I could sum it up, is hell.
War is the most chaotic
and unexpected scenario
you can find yourself in.
And we as a Western society,
we have a very interesting way
to regulate this terrible
phenomenon called war.
We call it the laws of war,
the laws of armed conflict.
For those of you
who do not know,
the laws of war are basically
a bunch of rules anchored
in different treaties,
international laws,
domestic ones, and customs,
and they define the dos
and don'ts within war.
They do not explain
to the commander
how tactically or strategically
operate within war.
How to maneuver with the tanks
or with the F-35s, but rather,
they define the general
moral guidelines
of how one should behave within
this terrible phenomenon.
I had the pleasure of dealing
with war issues for the past 12
or 13 years of my life
from different angles.
And as time went by, I started
to ask myself some questions.
What is the purpose
of these laws?
Is it to protect innocent lives
during combat like most of us
would have think?
Or perhaps from a mental
health perspective,
to make sure that
soldiers would not
engage in horrific scenes
which will corrupt their souls.
Others, cynical
scholars may claim
that those who shaped the
laws of armed conflict
did so in a way which
will help them--
or their nations-- to win wars
against less powerful actors,
also known as terrorist
organizations.
Yet the truth is a bit
more complicated than that,
and I simply know this
because I have been there.
As I was kindly
introduced, my name is Gadi
and I hold a dual
perspective on war,
both as a professional, as an
academic, but more importantly,
as a combat soldier
who knows how
the translation of these
laws looks like in real life,
in real combat.
And today I'm going to make a
very simple argument to you.
A strict adherence to the
laws of armed conflict
might put you on the
right side of the law.
You are not going
to be indicted.
Mazel tov.
Yet it might lead you to partake
in some horrific, horrific
scenes.
In order to avoid those scenes
yet to fulfill your mission,
you would occasionally have
to apply higher standards
than the legal ones.
If I may add, the low,
low standard legal ones.
And in order to prove
that point to you,
I would like to share with you
my personal story from Gaza.
But before we begin, two main
assumptions for this talk.
Number one, the scenes that I'm
going to describe to you today
are ones that I have sensed
from my own subjective senses.
So other people who
were among those scenes
might describe them
a bit differently.
And number two,
the views that I'm
going to share with you today
are my own personal views
and they do not represent any
governmental office or other
entity whatsoever.
OK.
So now we can begin.
So to talk to you about
my Gaza experiences,
I would like to take you
back precisely 10 years ago--
December 2008.
The state of Israel
is about three years
after the disengagement
plan in which
we evacuated any Israeli
presence from the Gaza Strip.
Two years after Hamas
took over the Gaza Strip--
the terrorist organization
of Hamas over the Gaza Strip.
And let's say that since Hamas
took over, the state of Israel
has suffered
thousands of thousands
of rockets being fired at our
villages in southern Israel.
I was a civilian at that
time finishing my three years
of mandatory military service--
I was actually a 1L student,
my first year in law school,
my first semester.
And it's a Saturday
night, and I'm
finishing a terrific weekend
in my parents' house, which
is located down south in an
area already bombarded by Hamas.
I'm driving my '95
blue Fiat right
inside Tel Aviv to begin
another week in law school.
And at some point during
the entrance to Tel Aviv,
I'm receiving a very
weird phone call
from an unidentified number.
I'm making the mistake and
I'm answering this phone call.
And on the other
side of the line
there is an automatic
message that basically asks
me to urgently arrive at our--
at my unit the
following morning.
Today we are very smart after
three different campaigns
in Gaza.
But back then, no
one really believed
we are going to war inside Gaza.
So the next day,
my teammates and I,
brothers from different mothers,
we are arriving at our unit
and we really happy
to see each other.
It's like a reunion.
A lot of high-fives, a lot
of hugs, a lot of coffee.
But very quickly we're
heading down south
to an army base in which
we spend the next week.
During that week, we had
a pretty clear routine.
During the days
we were training,
we were simulating the
different scenarios
we thought we were going
to experience inside Gaza.
During the night,
we were waiting.
We were waiting for the
final call to invade Gaza.
Each night we came
prepared with our gear,
with our vests, grenades,
magazines, rifles,
some candy bars for
the rough times,
and by that, I'm going to say
I'm not going to glorify war
to you because
that's going to be
a disrespect to
your intelligence.
Yes, we did made sure
we have enough candies
for the rough times.
It's essential sometimes
as other means.
And we would stand in
front of our commander,
and he would come and
he would look at us
and just say that every
night that everything is
postponed in 24 hours.
The invasion is postponed
in 24 hours, just like that.
Night after night after
night after night,
which lasted to a
nerve-wracking week.
I want you to think about
that feeling for a second
about a civilian that was
ripped out of his nice Espresso
routine in Tel Aviv
University, and he's
about to enter a territory in
which he could lose his life.
And he doesn't know when
this is going to happen.
I'm not sure the Geneva
Conventions nor the Hague
Regulations take these
emotions into account.
But after one week--
precisely after,
it was Saturday night again.
We were told that tonight is the
night and we're invading Gaza.
We were transported to
another military base,
this time much, much
closer to the border.
And there we got
an emotional speech
from a very, very high-ranking
commander in the paratroopers.
His speech was mainly focused
on Zionism, ideals, morales.
Let me tell you, if there's
one thing that I learned
after three years
in the military,
is that if a commander's speech
is primarily focused on Zionism
and ideals and less about
the particular mission,
this means things
are really bad.
And that was the feeling.
I was terrified.
If anyone will tell
you they're not
terrified before
going to battle--
in our case, to Lebanon,
to Gaza, wherever,
they're either liars or crazy.
I was terrified.
The walk.
The walk towards the Gaza
Strip starts about 1.2 miles
in Israeli territory.
And we are carrying an enormous
amount of weight on our back.
I'm carrying about 110 pounds
on my back of food, water,
ammunition,
camouflage equipment,
different stuff we
usually take in with us.
And during our walk, we are
accompanied by literally a wall
of fire being shot from
vessels, helicopters, artillery,
everything in order
to make sure that we
are going to arrive that our
destination the safest way
possible.
And our mission, our
mission was pretty clear.
We were told we needed
to locate ourselves
in front of the first line
of houses off the Gaza Strip.
Once you're going to
get there, we were told,
you need to camouflage
yourself, become invisible,
and constantly spot terrorists
in that first line of houses.
Once you're going
to spot a terrorist,
you're going to be allocated
with a helicopter or a drone
above your head, and the
helicopter or the drone
needed to help the terrorist
to reunite with God.
So the purpose was pretty clear.
We needed to make sure
that the surface is
safe for the rest
of the forces that
needed to invade that territory
about 48 to 72 hours later.
And after around
two hours of walk,
we were arriving at
a large sand dune.
Now we knew it in
advance because we
had the maps and
intel and everything,
but only when we got
there have we realized
that we were in a Jewish
village that was evacuated
in the disengagement plan.
We were literally the first
Israelis to go back there.
I vividly remember
still the old basketball
court of the village.
Some of the public facilities.
Some people find mezuzahs
in the ground, in the sand.
Yet we did not have
time for any nostalgia
because we did not
know two things.
We did not know if the
terrorists that were only 200,
300 yards away from
us at that point
has an ability to
see us at night.
But more importantly,
we did not know
if they have sniping ability.
So we were literally
in a race against time
to camouflage ourselves
the fastest way possible
before the sun comes
up and we're all
going to end up like
ducks in a shooting range.
And after additional two
hours of walk-- work,
our team is creating what we
call in the military slang
a camouflaged position.
This is basically a fake
artificial territory
that we're creating.
It is no larger from--
what is your name, sir?
AUDIENCE: It's Fred.
GADI EZRA: From
where Fred is to--
AUDIENCE: [? Eudor. ?]
GADI EZRA: To [? Eudor. ?]
And in that territory, which
looks like it's
an integral part,
like a line-- another layer
of the sand in the dune,
you would have six to seven IDF
soldiers that would sit inside,
and inside, they
would have to eat,
to drink, to communicate, to
do what human beings are doing
every three to
four hours together
with your teammates,
which can create
quite amusing scenes sometimes.
And again, conduct the mission.
Constantly look for
terrorists, once you're
spotting a terrorist, report
to the helicopter or the drone,
and then close the
circle of fire,
how would we call it
in the military slang.
And it did not
take long before we
have faced our first scenario
in Operation Cast Lead.
Around day two, we're
spotting on the third floor
of a building a terrorist.
He is looking for IDF
soldiers in the horizon.
He's clearly on an
intelligence mission,
he has no idea we're seeing him
because we're invisible to him.
But we are preparing
ourselves for an engagement.
We're talking to the
pilot above our head.
Now I can tell you
as a lawyer now,
that if we had the Geneva
Conventions right there with us
in that camouflaged position,
they would have told us
we are doing the
exact right thing.
The reason is a core principle
in international law called
the principle of necessity.
The principle of
necessity basically
says that weakening the other
party to an armed conflict
is a legitimate cause.
As a matter of fact, the
only legitimate cause.
Yet you would all agree with me
that targeting Hamas terrorists
in the middle of an
operation in Gaza for me
is a legitimate cause, right?
Yet life, as they tend to be,
were a bit more complicated
than that.
Because right next
to the terrorist,
we're spotting a woman.
We're looking at them
for over an hour,
and we're concluding that
she is not a terrorist,
that she is a civilian.
Now the laws of armed conflict
do acknowledge the fact
that civilians can
find themselves
at the middle of the
war zone as well.
And another
interesting principle
called the principle
of distinction
says that civilians are
immune from any attack
unless they are
directly participating
in the hostilities themselves--
DPHing.
Yet this woman was not DPHing.
She was probably there
against her will,
or at least we could not prove
that she was voluntarily there.
And then we were realizing
we're facing a true scenario
of a human shield.
Now I do not have a
sniping ability in my team.
Even if I would have, I wouldn't
take a shot with a sniper,
probably, although it's very
accurate and precise, because I
wouldn't want to
give away my location
due to operational reasons.
I'm on an undercover mission.
I do have a helicopter
above my head.
The helicopter has a
very lethal missile
that can go right through the
window, and if it's not clear,
take them both.
Does this mean
that the terrorist
shall enjoy the immunity
granted to the woman
according to the laws of war?
Of course not, because of
another interesting principle
in international law, which
is called the principle
of proportionality.
The principle of
proportionality basically says
the following thing,
and be with me,
because it sounds like
an equation in algebra.
You're smart people,
but try to hold on.
A military action is forbidden--
a military action is
forbidden if the collateral
damage it causes is excessive
to the military advantage.
If the collateral
damage it causes
is excessive to the
military advantage.
Now putting that in the
human being's language
for a second, what the laws of
armed conflict expect me to do,
a 22-year-old kid,
hungry, tired,
and missing my
girlfriend, is to evaluate
hypothetically how
many points will I
gain from targeting
that terrorist,
and hypothetically evaluate
how many points will I
lose from targeting that woman.
And if the number that
I'm receiving is positive,
I did the right
thing, and if not,
I might just perhaps did
a very, very bad thing.
Good luck.
I want to pause for
a second and ask you,
what do you think
the right answer is?
Let's make a quick
poll in the room.
Who thinks that under
these circumstances
where I have a terrorist
right in front of me--
he's holding an
AK-47, a Kalashnikov,
and he's looking
for IDF soldiers,
and I have a woman
right next to him--
that under these circumstances
I should not take the shot?
AUDIENCE: OK, can
I ask, [INAUDIBLE]
why does the shot need to
be taken in the first place?
GADI EZRA: Because my
mission as a soldier
there is to make sure that
no terrorist is surviving
and harming the
rest of the forces
that are going to invade
to that territory later.
AUDIENCE: Well because it seems
like we're missing information,
because you're only given one
specific means of neutralizing
that person.
And we don't really
have information
about the strategic
value of that person.
GADI EZRA: Well, war is
the kingdom of uncertainty.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
GADI EZRA: And I'm not
missing details for purpose,
but rather trying to give you
the true authentic way you
would look at it on the ground.
Now let me ask you
another question.
Those of you who
would take the shot,
may I ask you to raise
your hand, please?
All right.
Those of you who
would take the shot,
would you change your mind
if I will tell you that she
held a baby in her arms?
You wouldn't change your mind?
Because she did.
AUDIENCE: I
[? wouldn't ?] [? have. ?]
GADI EZRA: You would?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't.
GADI EZRA: You would not?
You would not take the shot?
AUDIENCE: I would
still take the shot.
GADI EZRA: OK.
I saw some of you kind of
like feeling uncomfortable
when I added the baby
component to that equation.
And the truth is, the terrorists
are doing that on purpose.
It's a known mean by them.
Now I remember
sharing that scenario
with a colleague in a Red Cross
conference in Geneva once,
and he was less struggling
than some of you here.
His answer was a
straightforward,
of course you can take the
shot, what's the problem?
And you know what?
Legally speaking, he
might be just right.
Guys, the laws of armed conflict
has acknowledged sometimes
far away excessive
collateral damage
than just a woman and a baby.
Sometimes five, sometimes
10, sometimes 15 people.
Depends on the military
advantage, of course,
in a given case.
But the equation is
relatively simple.
Yet I gotta tell you that once
you're there on the ground--
on the ground, things tend to
look a bit more complicated.
Because come on, let's face it.
This woman is not collateral
damage, she's a human being.
She has a face.
She has a name.
She has hopes.
Aspirations.
Past, present, perhaps a future.
Friends, family members-- I can
see one of them in her arms.
She's not just collateral
damage, she's a living soul.
So we decided to wait.
We decided to wait
for a time window
in which she would be allowed
to go to the restrooms
or whatever she
was allowed to do.
And some of us still
do remember the missile
going right through the
window and her running
away from the
building hysterically
with a baby in her arms.
We know she survived
because she ran on her feet.
The terrorist is no longer
with us if you're concerned.
But did we apply higher
standards than the legal ones?
Yes.
Did we make our lives
more complicated?
Yes.
However, can we sleep
better at night?
Yes, we can.
Absolutely.
After four whole days in that
camouflaged position, four
whole days, we were told
that the valley between where
we were and the
first line of houses
was already occupied by the IDF.
And the IDF has created what we
call in the military [HEBREW]
in Hebrew.
[HEBREW] is
basically a safe zone
framed by sand batteries in
which vehicles, tanks, jeeps
could park safely.
Soldiers could rest
there safely as well.
Usually supply of
food and ammunition
would be transported
to the [HEBREW]..
It's like a
must-go-through point
before things are being
distributed to the soldiers
on the battlefield.
Bodies of that soldiers would
be moved to the [HEBREW]
first, and only from there, sent
to burial in Israeli territory.
So we were told,
go to the [HEBREW]
and wait for your
next assignment.
We were also told, do
not leave the [HEBREW]
under any circumstances,
because if you
are outside of the [HEBREW]
with no permission,
the presumption is that
you are a terrorist.
And if you're a terrorist,
according to the laws of war,
you're a legitimate target.
Yet while we were
there, at some point,
the soldiers who are
guarding the [HEBREW]
are seeing an IDF soldier
walking outside of the [HEBREW]
towards them.
He's walking towards them
and they're screaming at him.
Hey, what do you do here?
Please identify yourself.
And the guy ignores them
and continues to walk.
Brother, please stop.
Who are you?
They scream at him again.
And he continues to walk.
30 meters, 25 meters, 20 meters.
Now because he looked so good--
he looked like a
poster of the IDF
rather than a skinny,
sandy, muddy soldier
like we were at that
time, they thought
he's from a particular
engineering unit called
the [HEBREW] which
is the equivalent
word in Hebrew for diamond.
So they're reaching out to
the guy for the third time.
And they're asking him, hey, are
you are you from the [HEBREW]
by any chance?
The guy stops, he looks
at them and he says,
[SPEAKING ARABIC] in Arabic.
That was a Hamas terrorist.
He was disguised
as an IDF soldier,
he had ammunition
all over his body.
And his plan was to
enter the [HEBREW]
and conduct what
would have probably
been the most horrific suicide
attack our country has ever
known in our war history.
I wouldn't be standing
here if this guy would
have replied in Hebrew.
He was probably excited, drunk,
drugged, whatever he was,
and he mistakenly
replied in Arabic.
Now we were furious.
We were mad at the
soldiers who guarded us.
Why are you conducting
this Q&A session?
What are you, Oprah?
Come on, guys.
This is Gaza, it's not a joke.
Do something more tangible.
Shoot to the air, shoot
to the leg, something.
Even now when I started
to describe that scene,
some of you looked at me
and said, that's not right.
It's not OK.
But you know what?
It actually took us a
very, very short time
to realize that they set
a great example for us
and helped us to save lives,
and I'll explain in a second.
Our next mission was
to locate ourself
in an apartment which is
in the neighborhood we just
looked at 24 hours ago.
Go to that apartment,
we were told,
and look over a
valley which contained
a lot of rocket launchers.
Once we're going to
spot a rocket launcher,
you would be allocated with
a helicopter above your head,
you have to report
to the helicopter,
and the helicopter would
close a circle of fire
as we would do in the military
slang as I described before.
So we're getting
into that apartment
and we are spotting the kitchen
as the most strategic room
in the house with the best view.
And we're working in the
kitchen-- we're not cooking.
We're playing with
shades and lights
and we're creating an illusion.
It doesn't matter how
we do it, but if you
would look from the outside,
you would see a dark empty room,
but from the inside, you would
have three, four, five IDF
soldiers looking right at you.
While we were
there, we were also
accompanied by a younger
team of paratroopers.
That team's sole mission was to
constantly look at the entrance
to the apartment to make
sure no terrorist is
coming and slaughtering us while
we're not paying any attention.
So there we were, two
teams in one apartment.
At some point in the
middle of the night,
that team is getting called to
conduct a different mission.
Which is fine-- war is
a very dynamic scene.
So they're standing
in a line and then
they're starting to
march away from us.
Now you need to
understand something
about the walk in war.
Unlike your initial
intuition, the walk in war
could be extremely,
extremely slow,
because of two main reasons.
Number one, the
physical conditions.
You are terribly
tired, you're hungry,
you're carrying an enormous
amount of weight on your back.
But number two and
more importantly,
because of operational reasons.
Every few hundred
meters, the soldiers
who were leading the
force would stop.
They would go down on
the ground and they
would look for terrorists
on the horizon silently.
After 60, 90 seconds,
while they're
making sure there are no
terrorists in the area,
they would signal to the people
at the back of the column
that the surface is clear
and they may proceed.
While they are doing
this, the people
at the back of the
column, technically they
need to go down on
their knees as well
and secure the column to
the sides and the back.
Now this, some would
describe it a bit Hollywood.
Because in real life, what
really happens sometimes
is that soldiers
tend to daydream.
They would have a snack.
They would talk to their
friends about how much they
miss their girlfriend,
and they have
to propose when everything ends,
and a lot of wedding proposals
started on those moments.
And some fall asleep.
Happened to me more
than once, by the way.
That I fell asleep
in the middle of war,
being woken up by a missile,
a shot in the background,
or a bullet somewhere.
Not something rare that
I'm describing to you.
And the same thing
happened with that team.
About a mile away
from us, that team
is going down on the ground,
they're looking for terrorists.
Some of the people are
kind of daydreaming.
The same thing happens with
the last guy in that column--
he's falling asleep.
The only problem is that
when this guy opens his eyes,
he realizes he's all alone.
The procedure, the
protocol is pretty clear.
Before you start
to walk again, you
have to look back to make
sure your brother is with you.
This team probably-- probably--
did not follow the protocol,
leaving that guy asleep.
I want you to realize
what happened here.
We're talking about
a 19-year-old guy
in the middle of war in Gaza
falling asleep, waking up,
looking left, looking
right, and he sees no one.
He has no radio
and no cell phone.
No nothing.
This is the nightmare
of a lifetime.
So this guy gets panicked.
Who wouldn't, right?
And he decides to run to the
first place he remembers,
which is our place.
During that time, my teammate,
one of my best friends,
is looking at the door--
he starts his night shift.
Before he starts
his night shift,
he's taken a glass
bottle and he breaks it
at the entrance to the building.
Any idea why he's doing that?
AUDIENCE: Noise.
GADI EZRA: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Noise?
GADI EZRA: Exactly.
For operational reasons.
So if anyone would step
on the glass fragments,
he would have an advantage
and the element of surprise.
And at some point in the middle
of the night, 2:00, 3:00 AM,
he hears someone steps
on the glass fragments.
He looks down, he
sees a black figure
with a gun screaming at
him, hey, I'm IDF, I'm IDF,
don't shoot, don't shoot.
Really?
Hamas did the same
thing 24 hours ago.
Now I can tell you as a
lawyer now that my friend had
any legal justification
to take the shot,
for three main reasons.
Number one, when
this is happening,
we got no indication on the
radio about a lost soldier.
As a matter of fact,
when this is happening,
they still continues to
march like nothing happened.
They have no idea
they're missing one guy.
Number two, we know Hamas
is using that method
of disguising to IDF soldier.
And number three, you tell me--
what is the reasonable action
expected from a combat soldier
that is being surprised in the
middle of the night when he
sees a figure and he cannot
see any identification
on the uniform because it's
completely dark and someone has
a gun in front of him?
I would probably take the shot.
To not be mistaken.
Yes, friendly fire is a
terrible, terrible incident,
yet this is just, I
guess, part of the reality
of whoever engages in this
terrible phenomenon called war.
And my friend is a better
soldier than me, probably.
And he takes just
one more second.
He reaches out to the guy and
he asks him, please relax.
What is your name?
And the guy mumbles hysterically
with literally tears
in his eyes.
AUDIENCE: How did you see
the tears when it's dark?
GADI EZRA: Because you can
hear when someone speaks to you
and he shakes with his voice.
It's pretty obvious
at that point.
And the guy mumbles his name.
Who's your commander?
What happened to you?
What are you doing here?
And after 25, 30
seconds of a dialogue,
he realizes he's not facing a
disguised terrorist, but rather
a true authentic lost soldier.
He's taking the gun down
and he's reaching out to him
and saying, hey brother,
you're safe now.
You may come, you're with us.
And the guy enters our
apartment, crashes.
Again, with tears thanking
us for not killing him.
We're waking up thinking
we're looking at a ghost.
But the truth is that
this guy is alive today
because my friend applied higher
standards than the legal ones.
The following
night we celebrated
Shabbat in that apartment.
Until this very day I remember
the davening in that apartment.
Something in the contradiction
between the ancient texts
of Kaddish of Friday
night davening and the way
we looked like
24th century robots
with the lasers and
stuff on our helmets.
That was something that just
was too much-- too hard to bear,
and I'm not embarrassed to say
even until this day that we--
some of us, we're
conducting this prayer
with tears in our
eyes, and it was
one of the most emotional
scenes of my life,
which I'll never forget.
The following day we
were transported back
to Israeli territory
for the first time.
We slept more than two hours.
We had a nice breakfast.
Nice.
Not Eggs Benedict.
Cucumbers and cheese
and military standards.
And then we were transported
back to the Gaza Strip again.
But this time,
not to a sand dune
and not to a lousy
apartment, but rather
to a very nice villa, actually,
inside the Gaza Strip.
There are such places in Gaza
and you should know this.
And I vividly remember
walking inside that villa,
and you could tell immediately
that this is the creme de
la creme of Gaza.
The father of the
family has a picture
shaking the hand of late
Yasser Arafat on the wall.
There are diplomas in French
and English on the wall.
The kid-- I remember the kid's
room until this very day.
The kid had a Sony PlayStation
with a very impressive library
of games.
"FIFA," "NFL," "NBA."
And I gotta tell you, we
were happy to be there.
If you're in war, then at
least be in a nice facility.
We also noticed, however, that
the family was kind of rushed
when they left the villa,
because their laundry were
still folded in a
weird way on the sofa.
Now think about it.
What we usually do is
that we fold laundry
in front of the TV, right?
And when we're done, we're
taking it to the closet.
What might have happened
with that family
was that they folded the
laundry, and then they--
that indication that
the IDF is coming,
and they just left
everything as it was.
But we'd not gave that too
much thought at the moment.
We entered the
living room and we--
some of us crashed on the sofa,
we wanted our backs to have
some relief--
it was literally
broken at that point.
And we started to find
ourself in the house
and to search the
house for bombs
before beginning to operate
from within the house.
But after 10 minutes, our
commander comes and says,
guys, change in plans,
change in plans,
we have to evacuate
this place immediately.
We were very mad.
We wanted to stay there.
But an order is in
order, it is what it is.
So we're standing in a
line in front of the door
and we're waiting to exit.
And our commander comes and he
says, wait, guys, not just yet.
What do you want now,
we're asking him.
And he says, well, we gotta
bring this place just the way
we got it.
So we're replying, wait,
we didn't steal anything.
What are you talking about?
It's not us, we'll
never do that.
He's like, no, of course not.
I'm not talking about that.
Look at the living
room, look at the mess.
The entire laundry is on the
floor because of you guys.
So I'm finding myself
at the age of 22
in the middle of
Gaza folding laundry.
Not in the best way.
When my wife first heard
that, she was like,
do it at home finally.
But literally folding laundry.
Taking a note from this tiny
notebook that I had with me.
I do not speak Arabic, although
my mother is an Arabic teacher.
And I do not know if
they speak Hebrew,
but I soon had a pretty good
sense that they speak English.
So I took a note and I wrote to
the family, sorry for the mess.
May peace come upon us.
Israeli Special Forces.
And I left the note on the
laundry and we left that villa.
Now I always share
that laundry story,
not because it's challenging
like the human shield story,
and not because it's frightening
like the disguised terrorist
one and not because it's
unbelievable like almost
friendly fire incident
my friend experienced.
I'm sharing that
story because to me,
it stresses the
simple notion that we
as soldiers in every
military are not just dealing
with collateral damages.
We're dealing with human beings.
And we're taking that
job very, very seriously.
Very seriously.
Now do not be mistaken.
We are not perfect.
You're not going to
hear that from me.
That's going to be
a blunt disrespect
to your intelligence.
As a matter of fact,
you can not be perfect
when you're dealing with war.
War is a dirty business.
Yet when mistakes happens,
and they do from time to time,
we investigate.
We press charges.
We indict.
We do anything in our
power to make sure
that these wrongdoings
are not happening again
and they maintain
as the exception
and not the general custom.
And we're not just doing that
because of them, by the way.
Again, do not be fooled.
We're doing that
also because of us.
Not to lose who we are.
Because-- and remember that.
I believe that there
is a direct link--
direct link between the way
a nation conducts its warfare
and the way it
conducts its society.
If we were to be barbarians
on the battlefield
just because we can,
these norms will
be integrated into our civilian
lives, particularly in Israel
where we are a military
of our own people.
We do not have a
professional military.
Those norms will be integrated
into our civilian lives,
harms our society, our checks
and balances, and that,
my friends, that would be the
end of the Zionist project
as we know it today.
Thank you so much for
coming and listening.
And if you have
any questions, I'm
more than open to hear them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]